I really love this place Good Vibes the
cello May complex was built from the
ground up to be the ideal comfortable
workplace mechanic glove I've been here
before
we make it for the speech oh we've got
plenty of time we can even go on rides
afterwards
on The Icarus platform a feat of modern
science and technology this city in the
clouds was built in 1950.
leading scientists from all the other
Soviet republics live here including
including German SSR
you need to have an exceptionally
brilliant and dedicated mind to work
here
would you care for some more soda
comrade
[Music]
sure thanks
looks like another bot got stuck in a
tree that always cracks me up
[Music]
still working on the robot's navigation
system yeah I noticed
wow what a beautiful day
foreign
what the hell did you do to them Let Me
Lie there all day number three is Bolt
honey these houses painted but look at
what they're doing in state
give me your control code I'll set them
straight oh picky sweetie
oh thanks mum oh the ghost zero four
five one
okay then get to work you bums move it
move it
whoa here did it oh thanks a million and
enjoy the celebration
good morning my boy how are you did you
sleep well good morning Dr section off I
slept fine awaiting orders how do you
like the new glove better than the old
one it's growing on me I'd expect
nothing less I designed the device
myself be careful with it now it's more
important than you might think yes Dr
suchnov I'll keep it safe report to the
lab to complete your integration with
the glove I've got a full schedule today
so Mikhail stockhausen will get you up
to speed I'll be in touch later Roger
that
[Music]
foreign
major there is a turbine waiting for you
the airway are your orders clear crystal
get off my case already I'm pleased to
hear you don't have any questions for
once
you
[Music]
oh
come raids Icarus platform residents and
facility guests
the address by the director general of
facility 3826 Dr sechinov is about to
begin
Gather in the Town Square to hear his
address
[Music]
[Applause]
advantage of sketch your thought device
today good day comrade come closer I'm
here to help
would you like a thought device it's
high time you got one
no thanks I'm just browsing
oh I restrict yourself to browsing when
you can get your own personalized device
that's very instant
I can even help you pick out the right
unit it can even match your eye color
hey how about a gooseberry Violet model
huh you are polymerized aren't you I
sure am say I thought these devices
weren't going to come online until
Monday
that's right comrade but judging by your
uniform you are clear to activate your
thought neuro connector right away
at the moment the device functions as a
personal telephone set and headlight but
it also allows the user to get used to
wearing it on their head
it's free right absolutely allow me to
connect you
all right then
please
[Music]
oh that's odd I can't seem to access
your biometric data
there's some sort of malfunction I'm so
sorry I don't sweat it I'm not really a
jewelry guy anyway so long I do
apologize have a great day
hey you experimental glove I get the
feeling you'll be more useful than this
goofy Contraption on my forehead since
you're so special and all you'll see how
special I am soon enough but you ought
to refer to me as Charles the chatting
artificial librarian and educational
system I'll call you whatever I feel
like glove
[Music]
treatment yesterday
you show us the photographs
[Music]
of people's Unity
comrades residents and visitors
[Music]
learn about their history and facility
3826 hear about its great discoveries
and pay your respects to all the victims
of war
[Music]
everyone here seems so happy and content
just like in China you've been to China
comrade major I've Been Everywhere I
mean everywhere except for China I guess
facility 3826 isn't all that far from
our Chinese allies I like their spirit
and I hear it's nice there indeed it is
[Music]
still can't believe the Stars can be so
close
it's as if I could reach out and touch
them with my hand
look at it such a breathtaking Beauty
when I was little I'd never have dreamed
people could soar so high imagine a chai
reporting for Duty on comrade such
enough's direct order welcome comrade
major today is a joyful occasion the
birthday of collective yeah yeah many
happy returns cut to the chase would you
have got places to be naturally
this is the future of Soviet education a
personal project of Dr sechinov's poly
education gone are the days when Soviet
citizens had to spend years studying at
educational institutions From This
Moment On just inject a special
neuropolymer encoded with the education
you want a university level Natural
Sciences curriculum for example and
you'll instantly become an educated
member of society want to learn Korean
or get a doctorate in nuclear physics or
learn to play the piano with Collective
2.0 you can yeah yeah yeah been there
done that skip the four play bot excuse
me of course
of course your particular case
definitely calls for something more
efficacious nevertheless you will still
need an initial neuropolymer injection
comrade such enough is expecting you
agent P3 I've been informed of your
imminent arrival here take this capsule
foreign
[Music]
you have just upgraded your glove with
scanner functionality using the
neuropolymer as a conduit the sensors in
your glove are now directly connected to
your neural system especially your eyes
polymer retina
to activate the scanner just make a
special gesture please choose an object
of interest and extend your arm toward
it the palm of your hand should be
facing the object contract all the
fingers on your hand except for your
thumb and index finger extend your thumb
and index finger to form a right angle
to activate the scanner holy shitbot who
designed this thing the Spanish
Inquisition
[Music]
demon be gone
for your information that's a highly
user-friendly gesture it was developed
by our leading expert in the field of
advanced interpretive avant-garde
absurdist dadaism whatever that guy's
been smoking sign me up
didn't say you were in a hurry just a
moment ago shut your trap and keep
scanning would you I'm getting
acquainted with the new hardware
you are now capable of seeing hidden
objects this ability could prove very
useful in the future but for now please
continue with your mission
[Music]
comrades the address by the director
general of facility 3826 Dr sechinoff is
about to begin
[Applause]
thank you
greetings comrades hi I'm Dmitry
sectionar and this is facility
[Applause]
the greatest event in the history
fun Change the World As We Know It
support to the lobby of that hierarchy
I'm not exaggerating they are waiting
just look at our beloved Soviet Union
has been a transformed for the last few
decades
thanks to my invention of Euro polymers
I've been process of pneumatic adoption
it has now become possible to launch so
glad to see you're taking it easy
comrade major of the collective the car
is waiting you must go to doctor section
of office for the access code humans and
left with one of his bodyguards the
control machines with their thoughts
alone and
I love this place no matter how many
times I come here it always amazes me
it's just so nice our elevator has
arrived
I present to you the device of the
future the neural connector
thought
it will allow
human beings to be at the center of
collective 2.0 a network For All Mankind
together
uniting the intellect of all individuals
into a powerful mind free of all
boundaries
thanks to the thought Euro connector you
will control robots with your mind
mastering academic subjects with
breathtaking speed accessing all human
knowledge and of course combining it
with your own individual
you will no longer need control panels
cumbersome Communications equipment and
loudspeakers documents electronic
notebooks Etc
thought will replace every single one of
them
and so much more
your potential will be unlimited or the
word a foreign language in a minute
Master quantum physics in a day memorize
literary masterpieces from around the
world
this all will be possible once your
thought neural connector is
let's talk about style science is power
I tell you the boss has a way of looking
down on insurmountable obstacles I
really respect that there are no
obstacles science cannot somehow other
than an electronic glove that never
shuts up here is your vehicle activation
code comrade major
[Music]
got it the vehicle is waiting downstairs
you should hurry you don't have much
time
we can take the same elevator we took to
get up here thanks Einstein what would I
ever do without you
[Music]
section off here sorry I can't meet with
you in person my boy the reporters have
been hounding me all day so what do you
think of cellame you've built yourself a
city of the Future boss there's nothing
else like in the whole USSR I built it
For All Mankind not for myself humanity
is on the verge of great discoveries one
day we'll reach the Stars these Castles
in the Sky will be the beginning of our
journey to the farthest reaches of the
universe I'm merely helping Humanity
realize its own greatness you're a
dreamer Dr sachinoff fantasy and science
go hand in hand most modern inventions
were described long ago in science
fiction flying machines space travel
even robots are you telling me you got
your ideas from sci-fi novels I got them
from the dreams of mankind P3 man was
born to dream to do great things
but unfortunately there are those who
wish to crush those dreams and that's
where men like you come in sege men
sworn to defend Mankind and its Destiny
need me to get rid of somebody boss
you're very relaxed about it my boy I
hope it won't come to that but let's
take it one step at a time first you'll
need a substantial glove upgrade report
to the lab a teresh gova robot will meet
you there and take you to the vavalov
complex understood yes sir I'm getting
in the car right now